RStudio Cloud allows
us to create assignments for our learners
via RStudio projects.
By creating assignments within an
RStudio Cloud workspace,
we set up a shared environment
for our learners to access and complete
their work. Assignments in RStudio Cloud
happen at the project level.
To create a new assignment
we click on the new project
button here in the top right.
Once we're inside our project,
we can create any files
we'd like our students to use
as part of completing the assignment.
This could include
an R Markdown document
with instructions, an R script
with partially completed code,
or any other type of file available to you
from within RStudio.
After we create everything
needed to get an assignment together,
we want to make sure that our learners
can access it by clicking on the project
settings button in the upper right,
clicking on the access panel,
and from the who can view this project
dropdown menu, choosing everyone.
The final step to
making this an assignment
is to check the box
next to make this project an assignment.
When we navigate back to our workspace
by clicking on the workspace
name at the top, we see that our project
is now listed as an assignment.
Our learners will see a corresponding tag
that says either start if they haven't
yet opened the assignment or continue
if they've already opened the assignment.
One thing to note is that if
we make changes to an assignment,
they will not be applied
to any copies of the assignment
that students have already created
by opening the assignment.
The changes we make to an assignment
will only apply to future
copies of the assignment.